allora già dal menu possiamo apprezzare
la faccenda per questo è in italiano
praticamente sakhir your self credo che
sia abbastanza autoesplicativo su cui
cosa bisogna fare è stato fatto da
italiani a quanto pare bravi non è
femmini friendly però è pixelloso quindi
non penso ci siano problemi bannati
stimo da youtube benvenuto a chi gli
orsetti gioco dove vinci se mi fai
morire viva
mi puoi controllare cliccando dove
clicky andrò ebbe immaginavo
se invece clic su un oggetto apparirà
questa roba qui descritto così click
azionare le icone per compiere un azione
va bene le azioni sono guarda usa prendi
e vai verso come vedi ci sono due
oggetti di sotto clicca su quello verde
scegli guarda
ecco dove era ho dovuto mettere ho
dovuto smettere di fumare perché non lo
trovavo ok un accendino raccoglie lo
come vedi l'accendino e ora nel mio
inventario
ok io che ti sta spiegando come
ucciderlo bellissima vediamo così usa e
microonde
esplode il microonde moio andato a fuoco
il microonde ricorda poi combinare
oggetti anche con altri oggetti di
alimentare ottima ora sei tutto ciò che
serve per giocare invertiti a farmi
morire
io per negati grazie peso sia stato
tutorial più bello della mia vita quindi
giochiamo basse senza lavoro senza
moglie tanto vale rimanere senza vita è
allegro allegrissimo comunque belle del
gioco
bravi in questo devo fare ma quando c'è
un tempo vi devo ammazzare comunque meno
male che studio aperto non ha mai visto
che un gameplay da genere se non sono
cazzo perché hanno due neuroni
cacciavite nel letto lucknow bar nel
letto hanno provato ormai lo hanno
ancora provato a dormire nel letto ma
l'inizio ma non c'è veramente un modo
per stracciarsi nel letto non esiste e
la cosa veramente più strana del mondo
penso sia da base da lì poi ovviamente
mimì pillole caccia abitate in bocca non
riesco ad aggiungere i cardini i cardini
auchan fermo fermo farlo forse ce lo
sfida smith e cardini o allentato i
cardini va bene e quindi adesso attesa e
no però stanco morto a tutti quegli anni
passati a montare mobili che hanno ti
hanno insegnato no ovviamente
anzi ancora peggio ma sai che non ho
capito cosa dovrei fare con lo champagne
e che lo champagne è proprio una roba
che di base non useresti mai è una
torcia questa non è una torcia comincia
il tutto però che potrebbe non essere
una doccia
vabbè lasciamo bird diego fuoco la
cellino a cellino alce nero solo
l'accendino dai e vago non riesce a
prendere forma come all alcol genio cioè
tutto qua tutta fisica guacho tutta la
fisica
credo però proprio cosa ci fa mi do
fuoco prodotti per la pulizia premino è
l'alcol
in media una torcia moto torcia
alimentata da certo come non è successo
niente ma cui è possibile a ecco torcia
accesa dagli poco a microonde cosa gli
do fondati fuoco e basta una torcia
accesa grazie certo che ho delle tasche
resistenti porca vacca mi piace troppo
l'ironia che c'è su giovinco di cosa
cosa me ne faccio una torcia accesa dai
fuoco al letto dai fuoco a casa dai
focolai alla casa la trave e quindi non
possono come no aspetta forse devo dare
fuoco a tutte e due le travi così crolla
la casa sarebbe geniale cosa è stato
jolo e c'è qualcosa che non va forse per
spiegato fuoco alle travi potrebbe
essere quello a è cascato mi è cascato
il soffitto in testa morte dall'alto
padroni di casa non sarà molto contento
è un bene che tu non sarai lì per
discuterne va bene ma tra l'altro adesso
e ci penso io potevo sparare perché qua
c'è una roba dove eccola la bombola del
gas
la bombola del gas non la puoi prendere
non puoi fare niente
il problema non è che puoi fare quello
che vuoi vedere che cosa succede al
massimo non succede
va beh ma tanto più che sta qua a
proviamo a far esplodere la bombola del
gas che potrebbe avere un senso di mano
no cellino non è questo il proietti
proiettile più che altro a questa cosa
devo fare per la pistola combinato il
proiettile
credo di dover sparare una bombola
perché sennò non ha un senso
facciamo allora un senso se già morto ma
non puoi spararti tu e basta
c'è delusione ma come mai non è quindi
non funziona non c'è modo di uscita si
con la pistola ragazzi ma porca vacca
aspetta che pero stan conoscendoli dias
non puoi metterci la faccia negli us
magari lo stesso lo sapevi e la bombola
del gas dei fornelli lo vedo a ora
salterà in aria perfetto
meno male che ho studiato ago due in
fisica non ci credo non ci credo si
rifiuta ancora display cosa devo fare
sono ma bari ovvero si può certo la
retta frase che ti viene in mente da
dire
ho appena vai a fuoco anche giovanna
d'arco ha detto in tutto questo ragazzi
c'è il modo adesso adesso lo faccio
perché è impossibile che non abbiamo
fatto cioè non puoi versare niente
prodotti per il mastro lindo ha usato
nel lavandino 0 idraulico league o nella
vasca da bagno ci faccio il bagno nel
idraulico liquido no dovevi riempire ho
capito fermi fermi apre i fornelli o
prendi il prodotto da poliziotto ce la
faccio a dire la parola pulizia pulizia
polizia pulizia due cose diverse
ora non è lo spunto lo scarico perché ok
va infatti si by privacy è morto ok
niente istantanea ma guarda ti sei pelle
rossa bepi rossa che pelle
effettivamente c'è anche radio comunque
devo ficcare qualcosa nella presenti
polare alla forchetta
c'è qualcosa che posso ficcare una presa
elettrica qualsiasi tipo la chiave la
chiave
la chiave nella presa elettrica fermi e
piccola ci sta prendi prendi la ci
dovrebbe stare dentro il coso porca
vacca avevo pensato
c'è di sicuro la roba da ficcarci dentro
perché per forza per forza ci dovrebbe
essere il eccolo cacciavite ce l'abbiamo
ce l'abbiamo cacciavite nella corrente
signori ce l'abbiamo
come a ya mahdi morire ma mori non
funziona più ma [__] devo far
uscire dall'acqua per terra prova a
farla fuori con lei la palla da bowling
solo che la fama lab uniche come la
faccia scendere la parola bolling che
come la te lo giuro una piccola piccola
più con la padella con la padella in
testa ragazza con la padella in testa
dorigo io fidati ok la pentola non la
padella sorry c'è una pentola in testa
mettiti la band metti la metti la
pentola se funziona me ne vado no
ragazza cioè non tira la palla da
bowling sul lo puoi sfondare la porta
sulla vasca sulla fans cattinara sulla
vasca non è successo ogni anno la vasca
di essere piena non è successo niente
andata a kakà sulla home page di
giustamente sul lavandino no sul vetro
successo
hanno ficcato dentro io volevo tirarla
c'è una palla da bowling dentro non
userò allora caga sciacquone a ecco
perfetto
io volevo spaccarlo però va bene anche
così adesso sono morto morto
sono scioccato in finale oggetti in ogni
buco che vedi non è un comportamento
maturo
vallo a dire ai morti di [__] questo
asse allentata ma non l'avevo vista c'è
la parola un indie mezzo prendi la palla
da bowling e ghisa lenta l'asse si è
allentata nido di vespe veste meglio
trovare il modo di liberarmene prendi le
si certo cacciavite caccia vitale palla
da bowling a le lenzuola lenzuola e
chrome a nord di do fuoco di default
prendi cosa vota di poco ma se non avevo
vicepresidente devi fare prima la roba
da bowling ft sbloccava sta cosa madonna
che geni allora l'ater teoricamente
dovrebbe funzionare se non con lo
shampoo anni zio o con la pistola ancora
meglio allora miglior se teoricamente
così dovrebbe bastare
sì sono incazzate ecco a cosa attenzione
pavimento bagnato abbiamo capito lo devo
buttare la palla lì e del pareggio
pagato ce l'abbiamo e poi devo fare
qualcosa dopo sicuro però ce l'abbiamo
togliti non ti puoi togliere le
pantofole tipo scivolare basta o
piazzare qualcosa vicino che mi faccia
uccidere non so come no non devi cagare
va beh fate mia pista porta che non sono
cosa c'è dietro
non solo per curiosità perché fino a qua
ho il mio dio
vado al sacco di roba nuova va bene così
ragazzi troppo troppo casino c'è un
sacco di roba con cui divertirsi ragazzi
a cominciare dal fatto che e pericolanti
materiale per il giardinaggio figo
concludo qua questo episodio perché
vorrei provarlo subito ma facciamo poi
il prossimo magari un topo mi ha morso
mica mori questa è chi yourself molto
strano ironico carino molto bello
soprattutto italiano quindi break con
incoraggiamo gli sviluppatori
videogiochi italiani col mio amico
samuel e ciò fanno un bacio e niente io
vi saluto ci diamo il prossimo episodio
e
[Musica]